hi everyone welcome back to another
edition of a gadget lab I am Michael
colori I'm Christina Bonnington coming
up this week we've got some news from
Microsoft some news from Apple we have a
very cool device to show you it's called
the midi-fighter 3d it's sort of like a
live performance controller for
electronic musicians who use software in
their laptop and then at the end of the
show John Bradley is going to bring on
the Lytro camera it's a camera that lets
you take a picture and then focus it
later using software on your computer I
can't wait to check that out very cool
first though we have a little bit of
tidbit of news coming from Apple next
week right they sent out invites for a
product event next Wednesday here in San
Francisco 10 a.m. and it looks like it's
going to be an ipad event so it's
definitely a touchscreen device yes the
image has a picture of what looks like
it could be an iPad in a large hand so
it's either gonna be like an iPad or a
large hand so the smart money is
probably only an ipad 3 at this point
and what do we know about it so far we
know that it's going to have a better
display yes let's have a Retina display
um and nothing else yeah improved
processor different camera maybe it's
going to be slightly thicker those are
kind of the main points there's also
speculation that Microsoft is gonna show
off some cell phone on it possibly
officer yeah some people were thinking
that we could be seeing Microsoft Office
for iPad cool well one thing that we
definitely did see this week in advance
of anything Microsoft may or may not be
announcing next week was a really nice
new version of Windows 8 yes the
consumer preview build of windows 8 it's
been available as a developer preview
since of two bullets in September of
last year was it illegal it yeah yeah
but so this is what I'm certain
different robotic speech circuits aren't
operating properly this is why I sit
behind a computer all day yeah but so
anyone can download it it's free and
it's pretty great it is basically a beta
build so there's some quirks blue
screens of death every now and then but
that's to be expected with pre-release
software though yeah now what you've got
is a tablet and that's what you tested
is this for tablets and for laptops and
for desktops it is so window Windows 8
is designed for tablets all-in-ones
desktops notebooks but now phones not
phones but it does share windows 7 Metro
interface is that the tile things didn't
flip around and looking like surf
facebook and stuff like that yeah so
you've got these live tiles they show
information like the mail icon will show
your most recent email than your
calendar shows what's next on your
calendar it's pretty convenient um I
like that I like it kind of better than
iOS is just kind of static little icons
that don't show you anything so instead
of like diving into apps like is the
paradigm now the apps come to you much
like what we see on other smartphones
like Android right with the widgets on
the desktop yeah like that yeah except
it's all styled very nicely it fits
together and these little rectangles
it's very pleasing to the eye and it's a
totally different desktop experience you
know instead of having you know the task
bar along the bottom or the top having
you know you can store your files
folders programs on the desktop you've
just got this live tile display it's
pretty cool I thought operating it with
them with a mouse might be weird but it
was actually pretty natural just a
completely different experience so is it
so by that comment do you mean that it's
more for touch it's more based on like
sort of touch interactions and the touch
paradigm yeah so the I mean these icons
are big they're touchable all of the
Metro interface is designed for touch
but you can just as easily use a
keyboard mouse to operate around very
cool well you can read Kristina's entire
walkthrough
which is quite lengthy and detailed and
informative and full of all kinds of
wonderful information and screenshots on
the gadget lab blog at wired com /
Gadget Lab all right let's go to an
interview that we conducted a little
while ago with Ian golden from
djtechtools about his midi-fighter 3d
control we're here today with Ian golden
from djtechtools and he has brought a
new device to show us it is the MIDI
fighter 3d yep this is the new
midi-fighter 3d it's a controller that
we're announcing pretty much right now
and what's cool about the 3d is that it
allows you to control things using the
controller in 3d space now this is this
is for people who do live performance
electronic music using software right
that's correct so what software does it
tie into any software that supports MIDI
so some popular ones might be able t'en
tractor live even garage so it's like
for DJs and people doing performances
and it allows them to what add effects
mixtrax yeah trigger drum samples what
would they use it for mostly so there's
16 high performance triggers these are
original arcade buttons the same kind of
arcade buttons that you found on a tech
game and street fighter it's very cool
it'll last a lifetime then we wanted to
bring in some really intuitive analog
expression so if you pick it up you can
start to use it to control whatever you
want by just moving the device rotating
it tilting it left tilting it forward so
you got an accelerometer in there a
gyroscope all both accelerometer
gyroscope and encompass instead of GPS
Angie it's got everything it tells you
exactly where it is in space giving you
really really absolute control you know
previously you might have used something
like a fader or a knob to do these kinds
of analog expressions but when you have
something that's waited in your hand
you can really feel its movement and
combine several axes at the same time it
gets really expressive that's very cool
so like this this thing that you just
touched over here this is like a
traditional sort of live performance /
DJ controller that I would use for
software and this is obviously much
bigger than what you guys have come up
with yeah exactly this is a new
controller that also just came out this
is the vci 400 en golden edition
something that I designed with vestax oh
wow and this is the format that you're
typically seen right now it basically is
the turntable mixer paradigm you know
two turntables and a mixer and a
microphone yep and a lot of trigger
buttons and a lot of buttons so it's
just condensed into a smaller format
you've got one song over here one song
over here and then you're mixing the
various sources in the center and this
is great for mixing the problem is as
you notice there's a lot of buttons so
what we have tried to do with
midi-fighter series is condensed a lot
of this functionality into a small very
intuitive format where you don't need
labels you just kind of understand
intuitively what the instrument does and
it's also kind of cool because like you
keep using the word instrument and it
really does turn the traditional
controller into an instrument yeah like
with especially with all the tilting and
yep how you can fire different effects
and you know trigger different samples
and things by pressing the buttons yeah
it's like you can really get into it and
stand up and play and people can
actually watch you yeah exactly so the
thing is with new software there's all
these parameters and all these ways in
which you can interact with the music
and so what we were lacking in the
hardware world was actually an intuitive
and expressive way of accessing that
stuff you can literally get in and
really participate in the music remix in
it affecting it chopping it up on the
fly and what we do at Digitech tools is
design interfaces that allow you to kind
of tap into that world without getting
lost in the computer that's very cool
and you make them here in San Francisco
right we do we do this is actually a
device that we were building today so
you go on the website this is a first
midi-fighter and they can customize what
color buttons they want what color top
what color case we build it for them by
hand one by one and then each of them
comes with
certificate of authenticity and we've
been making these for a couple years are
super popular and now this is the new
bigger brother that adds this analog
expression that's very cool and so this
is fully programmable so no matter what
type of musician I am and no matter what
type of software I'm using I can program
this to incorporate any aspect of my
performance right yes yes the idea is
that it's a template and you should be
able to create whatever you imagine so
maybe you might map this to one
particular thing in this to another and
it just really depends on how you want
to express yourself that's great yeah so
how much are they going to cost and when
can we buy them so it's going to cost
you forty nine and they're going to ship
at the end of March that's great
djtechtools calm thanks to ian for
coming by and showing us the MIDI
fighter 3d nice thanks for having me
Michael alright we're joined now by John
Bradley hi John how you doing Mike I'm
good but I'm curious what is that giant
butter stick size thing you have there
this is the butter of the future it's um
this is the light show light field
camera that everybody's been talking
about for months it's finally launching
on the market today while they're
shipping it to the people who had the
foresight to order it back in November
December they're backordered quite a bit
so you can't actually run out and buy
one of these today but if you ordered
one it's in the mail and it will be to
you in a matter of days so everyone's
been talking about it but what is so
special about it um it's a unique take
on photography this takes what's called
the light field so if you think of a
normal photograph is two dimensional
which obviously it is it's actually
taking a photo of a plane in space and
that's what you focus on everything else
in front of that are behind that is
blurry this captures the entire called
light field and what you can do is go
and refocus after the fact so in effect
you can't take an out-of-focus picture
you just take the picture right away
without even focusing or anything and
afterwards you go in and choose where
you want it to focus and that's not
static anybody else can look at it and
decide to focus somewhere else hmm keep
playing around with it so a fixture a
picture is never really finished so I
can I can choose my focus on camera on
the camp well you can choose a focus on
the camera or you can just snap away
choose your focus afterwards but either
well I mean after I've taken a picture
can I is there screen on there I can
look at yeah absolutely there's a little
it's it's too small unfortunately um and
not a very high resolution i think it's
128 pixels across and you can you can
see the dots here and focus is such a
fine-tuned feature these photos that the
screen kind of under serves at but yeah
you can't go in afterwards and play with
the photos here it's a lot more fun to
load them onto your desktop or put them
on facebook or something will play
around with them so would it runs
special software on your desktop so you
plug it in and you edit the photos on
your desktop right well you don't really
edit them there's not a lot of editing
capability right now you take the photo
you download it to the desktop and then
their desktop utility is really simple
you just plug your camera and it
automatically rips all the photos off
and then you can choose to share them to
Facebook Twitter or whatever and the
neat thing is the software that enables
all that refocusing after the fact
travels with the photo oh so you just
put it on Facebook and anybody who has
flash enabled on their computer can look
at your photos on Facebook and refocus
it to their heart's content so it's you
know I think of it less as capturing a
moment than creating kind of user
experience people can go in and you know
it's kind of like choose your own ending
mmm how's it photo so it's it's like a
lot more social and just sharing a photo
you're sharing the photo and letting
your friends take their hand and editing
it yeah absolutely i mean i think you
know any photos ostensibly kind of
social you want to share that with
people but here you don't just show
people what you took you kind of share
it with people and let them create their
own experience with the photo which is a
unique take on things that's very cool
it's pretty neat well you can read
john's full review of the lytro on the
product reviews website wired com /
reviews and we'll be back next week with
everything that we can tell you about
whatever it is that Apple may or may not
be announcing next week plus I'm sure so
yeah on march seven I didn't know that
you didn't watch the beginning in a joke
anyway we'll be back next week with
apple news and other cool gadgets to
show you from the gadget lab it's even
you